(speaking french)
Matias, thank you for joining.
Thank you for having me.
Really happy to be here.
I'm really excited to chat
because you have a very unique background.
You've crossed a bunch of worlds.
You work in consumer products.
You worked on developer platforms
like at Facebook in the early days
and now leading product
for Alchemy in the crypto space.
But what I find even more interesting
is that you're not an engineer by training,
and yet you're building
more than many engineers that I know.
How do you go about it?
I think it just comes down
to being interested in a lot of things
and trying a lot of things over time
and getting better and better as models,
I guess, get better as well.
That's awesome.
So today you're using AI a ton at work
and outside of work.
But let's start with, like, Alchemy.
Like what was, aha moment you had maybe
kind of bringing AI to work?
The first thing that I remember
the first time we used AI,
I guess it was Codex in Slack.
Right.
It's probably a year ago
or so at this point.
Yeah.
The first thing we used it
for was to make small edits
to our documentation,
our developer docs from Slack.
So we went from having to run the site locally and
doing that whole process
that is fairly involved.
To just being able to add Codex on Slack in
the docs channel in our company Slack
and to be able to
just tell it to make changes.
We do that all the time at OpenAI too.
We still do it.
Now we have a bit
more of a sophisticated setup
but that was really
the first thing that we used
Codex for and AI in general at the company.
From there, the other big moment I remember
that was probably the bigger turning point,
was using code review.
And so there was this instance,
we had a small incident
that was related to a big migration
that had happened months prior.
And in big migrations,
some bugs will happen.
It was like a lot of code.
We had an internal postmortem
about the incident
and we basically identify
what the race condition was.
We fixed it and someone on the team had
the idea to retroactively run code review, Codex,
to see if Codex would have caught the bug.
And it did.
Wow.
And so we did that a couple of times just to see.
People were starting to get curious and
you could tell that was a bit of a turning point
in terms of model capability
and like a lot of the ingredients were right for for teams to start adopting those tools more.
From there, I remember a couple of days after seeing
one of the engineers on the team
essentially using Codex review
in pull request comments as his teammate.
He was just he submitted a PR that I saw
go through Slack.
I click through it
and I saw him do at Codex review,
address the comments that Codex would come up
with, then review again.
Do that again and he was just
doing this back and forth with Codex.
You could tell that people
were getting over the hurdle of,
of like thinking that LLMs weren't
good enough to help in a professional setting
with a really large complex code base,
with code that needs to be good enough
to be served to a lot of people.
That’s really cool.
That was really a turning point.
Yeah, that's
a very interesting point on code review.
I remember talking to many companies
were just getting into like, you know, AI coding.
Code review was the first moment when they realized
that many incidents they had could be
caught actually by Codex automatically.
And they replayed some of those similar
to Alchemy.
I remember Datadog, for instance,
back in January, said that
like more than one incident out of five
would have been saved by Codex.
But I'm sure the model capabilities
now are so good
with GPT 5.5,
it could be more than half, easily.
Nine out of ten, maybe.
Maybe most of it.
Yeah. So code review was really
a turning point for many companies
to get into Codex and really realize the power of AI.
Can you tell me a bit more about
how you're using Codex at work today?
I use it a lot for a lot of different things.
A lot of those typical product management
sort of tasks, writing documents.
We've created all these skills
internally to help us
do the PM job more easily
and better and faster.
That includes writing PRDs, analyzing customer feedback, like doing all those things.
I use Codex for that
and several members of the team reuse
those skills as well.
We have this shared, repo of skills across the company,
across all the different functions,
so that not only we can do the same
job and the same tasks faster and better
but also more people who are not
necessarily PMs are able to do those things.
I'm sure, yeah.
And I think it's also telling a lot about,
like, how we think about developers now,
not just as humans but also as agents consuming our own platforms and infrastructure.
We have to think about these agents and
making sure that, like, tools like Codex
can actually integrate, like OpenAI’s API
or Alchemy’s infrastructure very quickly.
Yeah, it's really several things
that change at the same time.
First, the way we work has changed and Alchemy
has a lot of very technical products.
It's an infrastructure company first.
And so all the developers
internally have changed the way they work.
And so it's
that's very clear to everyone now.
But that also means as builders
of a developer platform, we have to change
the way we build tools
so that other developers that we know
are also changing their workflows with
AI are able to use Alchemy better.
So it's, the developer we're building
for has evolved.
Now, we are very much assuming
that 100% of developers are building
software with the help of AI.
Right.
And so it's evolving your platform
to fit that new reality as one thing.
And then the other thing that's a bit more nascent
but that's also very interesting is, I guess,
this new type of developer that's an agent
sometimes, autonomous agent.
And they don't
always need the same tooling.
They need different things.
And if an autonomous agent
shows up on Alchemy
and as far as implementation decisions
go, they're fully autonomous.
They have to be able to sign up
and integrate something
and use the blockchain to perform
some kind of tasks.
We need to build the tools for that.
And it's building for those two.
And over time those two probably converge.
But for now
they're still fairly different needs.
And my job is basically
to try to figure out what we do for both.
Awesome.
Zooming out of Alchemy
a little bit, I was reflecting recently
about my own startup.
And you were a founder before, as well.
How do you think now, about this time
where you had to build without AI?
It was very different.
And it was hard,
even if you were not an engineer.
Even more difficult, like the typical way
you'd go about it 6 or 7 years ago
was to build some kind of prototype,
to try to raise enough money
to hire a small team, to
then build the real thing.
And that that's pretty much what I did
with with my company at the time,
built the first prototype myself.
It was very difficult because it was essentially copy pasting code left and right until something worked.
Managed to raise a bit of money,
hired a team of 3 or 4 engineers
to help build the first MVP
and not only that took,
a decent amount of money
and several people, but also took months.
I mean I haven't thought about this much
but I wonder how long it would take me
to build the first version of the app
we’re a building at the time with AI today,
just by myself.
My guess is that
it would take less than a week.
I don't know
what your experience was like.
You are building a much more complicated
product than mine, I guess.
How long did I take it back then
and how many people?
It took me a team of like 15 engineers
for maybe a year and a half
to get to like the first
like milestone of a V1 that we shipped
to like many customers.
It's pretty incredible how far we've come.
Like it's just never been easier
to do something.
Yeah.
And to start something from scratch.
It's probably the best time to be a founder.
Like any idea you have,
you can just build it.
Yeah.
Anyone who has an idea
now has the tools to basically try it out.
Speaking of things that you do
on the side, it's a great segue
because I wanted to ask you
about how you're using AI outside of work.
It sounds like you're building so many projects these days
it's almost like one a day.
You know, it's amazing because it's
never been easier to build things.
And yet I just kept feeling
this sort of anxiety
that I, I wasn't doing enough
pretty much all the time.
I think I'm a bit past that.
But the reason I am
is because I try to work
on a setup that allows me to spend
little time on my computer
and have essentially Codex work for me
for hours while I'm doing something else.
It's like
I had gotten to a point a few months ago
where I felt bad about going out
because I felt like
I should be taking advantage of this
amazing technology we have and I should
just be building things all the time.
I didn't want to do anything else.
I didn't want to feel like that either.
I didn't like that trade off.
And so I invested in a set of skills
and a process and several things
that I set up for myself
to basically be able to very quickly
either describe a new idea
and have Codex come up
with a plan, implement it, test it,
and let me know when it's done.
And it's very easy to to get Codex
to work for hours at that point.
Or if I have an existing product
and I want to explore new things,
I came up with this way
of essentially having Codex
do research for me on what new features
I should build.
It will look at other competitors.
It will look at other ideas.
It will try to figure out
what my goals are
and what my own preferences are.
And I created this set of skills
that basically gets Codex
to build all those things.
So it comes up with ideas.
It builds them in a modular way.
So it's going to feature
flag them and build them
as experiments in the main app
so that I can prompt Codex before going to bed
to go do some research about an app that I have.
Tell it to build the top
ten features it can come up with,
build them as experiments in the product.
Wake up to ten feature flags
that I can toggle on and off
automatically to basically
not be the bottleneck
when it comes to generating new ideas
but still having the control of deciding
what is good enough to stay in the project or not.
I love that.
That's really cool.
It's like without
spending a ton of time on a computer
have these moments,
like during my lunch break at work,
I have my personal laptop
and I try to send things to Codex
so that it can work
while I go back to work
before going out on weekends to dinner,
or to have drinks before going to bed.
I have these Codex moments, I guess, where
I just try to dispatch a bunch of work,
use all these processes
and these workflows I have with skills
and other actions so that Codex can work
while I'm not paying attention.
And it's amazing how much you can do
if you kind of invest in it that way.
That's so cool.
I mean, honestly, I would love to see your setup
and how you're using the Codex app
and kind of bringing all of these tools together.
Yeah. Let's check it out.
Let's check out linear to start.
So what you see here
is basically a collection of projects.
You see there's this 12 of them
in progress. At the same time.
I'm not working on all of them
in one go, but maybe we can pick one
and I can show you how this works.
This one, for example is a mac app
that since then
I've also built it as an iOS app
that uses Codex App server
to essentially help me write better
while I'm at my computer.
It's something that I built for myself
for work first, and that,
I kept building out since.
The way it works
is that you have a global shortcut.
In my case,
it's like command shift spacebar,
and it brings up this little window
that you see there.
That's cool.
And this is using Codex App Server.
So in the settings it's using my GPT
subscription behind the scenes.
And if you were to write something
in my case, I'm not even going to write.
I usually talk to my computer just because
it's so much faster for everything.
Like people at work a year ago
would make fun of my little headset.
I basically looked like a call center.
Call center operator.
And now a lot of people have those
similar headsets, so it's okay.
But if you say you're on slack
and you want to write something,
Yeah.
but you need to clean it up
and you want AI to make it sound more professional
or fix typos or things like that
like I'm going to record something
that would be like,
“Hey, I'm not totally sure
I understand what you're saying.
Maybe we should just get together
and figure it out” or something like that.
Obviously, this is not a great sentence.
I just dictated that to my computer.
And then if you hit command return
in this case,
it's going to rewrite it for me
in a way that sounds more professional
because the professional mode
was selected.
This is basically using Codex Server
behind the scenes and GPT 5.5.
You have a model picker.
I just added
5.5 since it just came out.
And this is just an example of a little
app that I made for myself for Mac.
I put the same setup in an iOS app
after to have
like a keyboard extension and help
you rewrite things quickly and so on.
I don't know if a lot of people use their,
their Codex subscription
for things that are not just coding.
I know that people use
the Codex app server to build other
coding interfaces,
but in this case I basically used it
because I wanted the inference to be done,
through my ChatGPT account.
And if we go back to to the process
and how to find time,
what you see here is this linear project.
I didn't create this project.
There are like 159 issues
that are done, a bunch that are in review
and some that are in progress.
I did not create
or write a single one of these.
Wow.
Codex did.
What I did is to talk to Codex
about what I wanted
through these skills
that I wrote for myself, to basically help
me create
a plan that turns into milestones
that you see here, like the foundation
and the preferences and so on, a bunch of the features.
Codex will create that plan,
break it down into milestones,
create the tasks,
work on them in a way that makes sense
based on this agent’s .md file that I created,
that essentially summarizes
the way I like to work.
And I put in a bunch of time and,
putting that in a single file.
So when I create a new project
or I have a new idea, I can basically just
initialize that project with that
agent’s .md file.
From there, I use this skill I have to create a plan
and after that it's just telling Codex, build the plan.
That's really cool because you're
using linear as the interface
as like your backlog and your release
milestones and things like this.
But like Codex is not just writing
all the issues, it's also picking them up
to close them and work on them.
Yeah.
It's of both delegating the,
I guess, the project management
and the setting up of the project and the
milestones and the tasks as well as the
the execution of the tasks too.
I’m initiating the project, sharing the initial idea,
giving Codex enough information about my preferences
and what I want the product to be
so that it builds
the version of the product that I want.
I think the biggest gap
when you code with LLMs, when
if the LLM produces something that's
surprising to you, in a negative way,
it didn't do what you wanted, usually it's
because it had to make one or
multiple assumptions and it just didn't
make them in the same way you would have.
And so in order to avoid that,
I have this process
that requires me to clarify
all those things upfront.
And once Codex has all of that,
it can just go and build.
That's really cool.
And so that's the first part and if you go back to
to this writing app as an example, the next step after
setting up a new project, building a V1 of a product
and having Codex essentially do all the work for me,
usually while I'm not even on my computer.
I wanted to find a way to generate
new features and keep working on a
on an existing product
without being the bottleneck.
I didn't want all the ideas
to have to come from me
but I still wanted some level of control
when it comes to deciding whether or not
I like that feature.
Right.
So I came up with this process
that is basically a way
to build experiments
with Codex on an existing project.
And it's a skill, again, that
essentially
has me tell Codex I'm interested
in building features in this direction, or
this is the high level goal that I have.
Go do some research about what
types of features you could build.
Go figure out what the competitors to
my products are building, things like that.
And it will come up with a lot of features based on what I'm saying.
And it's going to set them up
and build them with feature flags
as experiments in the code base.
And what that means is that you're able
to do things like what you see here.
You have
You can flip any switch of any feature.
That's right.
So you have a long list of
of experimental feature flags.
These were all built in one go.
One evening while I was sleeping.
So before going to bed I said,
“Hey Codex, I'm building this
AI writing assistant for myself.
Go figure out who else is building that.
What kind of features
do they have?
Score the ones that are most interesting,
most impactful, something like that.
Build all of them but build them
in a modular way so that when I wake up,
I can toggle each one on or off
independently to see if I like them.
And so you basically see
a list of all of those there.
We can pick a few if you want to see.
Like we're going to output
language is basically going to translate
Sure.
just going to
It’s fascinating that you did not use Codex just to make the plan and implement
but also use Codex
even before to make the research online
about what the feature should even be.
Yeah.
And so Codex is great.
It's it's way better than me at doing
research.
It doesn't it doesn't get bored of
searching for things.
And so as long as you tell it
what to research
and how you expect the findings
to be structured
and in my case, you also tell me
what to do with those findings.
It's basically just a sequence of fairly
small steps.
but it will do all of them in one go, because it's all encoded in a skill or a set of skills.
And so it's able to come up
with all of this build all of it,
build in a way that makes it easy
for me to test
and makes it easy for me to decide whether or not
I want it to stay in the product.
And so we selected a few here.
If we go back to the rewriting.
They just showed up instantly.
They just show up there.
And so in this case you see that
you have a translation feature.
In this case you can change the
the output format of the message
as an example.
It's like Slack style.
Yeah.
And so those are all small features
that I got Codex to ideate
and build in a way that,
makes it really easy for me
to essentially decide
if I want that to stay in the product
or not.
So, those are all the things that I ended
up coming up with to try not to spend
too much time building in a way but
still end up building quite a few things.
It's really cool.
Instead of starting from scratch, it's
basically
trying to think about the things you do
repeatedly, or even trying to think
about the ways you like to do things,
putting that into a skills,
putting some of that in an agent’s .md file.
Sometimes it's additional tooling and other things that make you go even beyond that.
And then having AI do most of the work.
That's awesome.
Have you built any other like projects
on top of the Codex Observer?
Maybe more like on the coding side?
I built a few things like,
this is an AI writing assistant.
It's a mac app.
It's a consumer.
I use OpenClaw and I've built a couple
of other things on my phone, even an Apple Watch app.
That are
It was just me tinkering, trying to see if I could have
different or new entry points to start a coding job, essentially.
So, in OpenClaw, for example,
I set up my OpenClaw that my assistant's
name is Lou has got a pretty funny
profile picture if you want to see it.
Yeah.
It’s
look at this guy.
[Laughs]
So what do you do with your OpenClaw here?
What do you talk about?
This little guy, Lou, it
basically, it mostly has two jobs.
The first one is to make jokes
in group chats with friends.
It's not very useful
but it's quite funny.
The second one is to just help me code.
And so it's connected at home.
It's running on a dedicated machine.
It's got access to Codex
and it's got integrations
that make it easier for me
to do certain things on the go.
For example, I have an OpenClaw discord and Codex integration,
so that I have a bunch
of discord channels.
Each one is bound to a specific repo.
And so if I want to do something
from my phone on the go and I wanted to
to be able to run at home
and do things that maybe aren't so easy
to do yet on the cloud
or things like that.
I can just do it
while I'm walking around somewhere.
I talk through discord by talking to Lou
and it's going to work on Codex.
That's an example.
Another thing that I did recently
was try to see if I could
build an Apple
Watch complication on the home screen
so that you could record a short voice
memo and have that trigger a Codex job.
So, like, imagine you found a typo
on a website or something like that.
Obviously it mostly works
for one shot things but you would just
very briefly like you would record
a voice memo to say, “Hey,
fix this typo on the landing page of this website.”
And you have the watch and you have
the companion iPhone app to do that.
Yeah. So, let me show you this,
this thing that I built.
This is my Apple Watch.
What I essentially built here
is a way to just send a voice memo
like create a test.md file
in my skills repo.
And that basically sent that memo
to this iPhone app.
That is now, it transcribed the message,
it understood the intent.
Based on that message is going to route it
to the correct place.
In this case, it's going to understand
that the skills repo means my own personal skills repo
because it has context
on my GitHub account
and then it's going to run the execution of that task.
So in a couple of minutes I'm basically going to get a notification
that says it created a
That second one is now successful?
Yeah.
So now it's running the execution here.
And this is all running with
like Codex app server behind the scenes?
Yeah.
So if you if you go to the settings here,
you basically see that,
there's two different ways it can run.
There's the typical you put an openAI API key and you can do it that way.
And the other one,
what is here called back in session
is basically Codex
app server running somewhere else.
That's so cool.
Roaming off of my account,
connected to my GitHub with all my context.
I love this.
I can basically just start Codex jobs on the go.
It's like
it's not useful for everything
but it's one of the ways
that I kind of like to play around
with what becomes possible.
It's like one step closer to making
I guess, the entire implementation
and implementation detail.
It's like I just talked to my watch for 10 seconds and it did
absolutely everything the right way.
Incredible.
I don't think we're always there yet,
depending on, you know, how complex
the actual ask is, but for small things
it's kind of convenient.
It was kind of fun to play around with just to see
how to work with Codex App Server.
And yeah, I just kind of try to do that.
And by the way,
this is exactly what I love to see, right?
Like we open sourced
the Codex CLI, the Codex harness,
and we also open sourced the Codex app server just for like fostering this like open ecosystem.
Like a builder,
like you can extend the way
you use Codex in this case
from your watch or your phone.
Even though, you know,
we have not shipped that yet.
So this is really, really cool how you can
use your coding agent the way you want.
I think you guys should build that
I think we should.
That complication on Apple Watch and on my iPhone home screen so I don't have to do it myself.
That'd be great.
Sounds like a great idea.
Let's see.
Look at that.
The whole request just arrived.
The request is right there.
Alright, out of this test.md file obviously
not the most useful task but
but it just shows that it works.
It's kind of fun to build as well.
Pretty cool.
That's really cool that you build this.
And by the way this is exactly why
we open source not just to the Codex CLI
and the Codex harness
but also the Codex App Server.
We want builders like you
to be able to kind of poke at it
and also integrate that in their own ways.
It's really cool
that you can have a coding agent
from your watch,
which we don't have it just yet, you know.
You better build it.
We we probably should build it.
Yeah.
It's a great idea.
I'm curious,
like, we launched a ton of things
in the past, like, few weeks,
both on the Codex side and GPT
5.5 our latest model.
Have you had some, like,
surprising moments with these two?
Yeah, there's a couple of things.
The first one I use computer use recently that was,
it was a lot better than what I remembered or I guess I was surprised by how good it was.
I was at home last weekend
doing something on a Raspberry Pi
and I needed to to do something
pretty tedious.
Like copy paste a bunch of different domain URLs and go
put them in some admin panel somewhere.
And I didn't really want to do it by hand.
So I told Codex to basically SSH
into the Raspberry Pi.
It was like dangling from a TV to go
do it for me.
And it just did.
Wow.
It found a way to just connect
to the Raspberry Pi through my browser.
It basically found all these URLs
that I had in a file that I gave it.
It just did the whole thing.
What was funny is that I was trying to use
computer use, I guess, to save time.
And I spent the entire time just watching it.
That’s so funny.
Doing the thing for me because I was impressed
by how I was going to the right place,
opening the right thing,
copy pasting stuff for me.
It was just the funny thing.
I love how the cursor moves also
in that you can kind of follow along the animations.
It's pretty but you don't want to touch it
but you kind of do at the same time.
Because you can actually let it disappear
in the background too.
Yeah, that was pretty cool and recent.
The other thing
I guess is 5.5 just launched
and I have this old hackathon
project that I've had for over ten years
that I use almost like my personal eval
in a way, that is,
I know that models
nowadays can one shot this project
but every time a new model comes out I try to do it again
just to see how much better it gets.
How many more details
it gets right. How the design improves.
It's a bit of a silly project
but I can tell you about it.
It was, it's a thing that was called
SnapCat, which is a bit absurd.
It was basically this app for cats
to take selfies.
And the way that it works is that,
I mean, I guess I could just show you.
But it's essentially
a black screen with a red laser dot
that moves around.
And
For the cat to catch?
Right. And so if you are a cat,
we can pretend you're a cat for a second.
And you try to catch that.
Every time you did
and if you don't mind
trying to tap to catch the dot.
I guess I'm not as fast as a cat.
You're really not a very good
I just did.
I think I got it.
There you go.
So as you do that,
every time you hit the viewport
you’re basically taking a photo
with the front facing camera.
Woah
And so you can exit this cat mode
with the volume buttons,
which cats don't really have easy access to.
At that point you go to the gallery.
You see the upside down pictures you just took of yourself as a cat.
You can basically select one, share it and that kind of stuff.
And what's cool here is two things.
The first one,
it easily one shot this project.
It's something that over ten years ago
we did at a hackathon.
It took us over a full day to build.
We had a team of five people.
It was quite difficult
to do really quickly.
Now this is one really well
crafted prompt and a couple of skills
and it can build the whole thing for you
in one go.
How did you build the UI?
Was it like 5.5 building the UI? Was it image gen?
That's the second thing, so the first thing, it can one shot the skeleton of this app really easily.
What it did in this case after that was
I described the style of an app
I wanted.
I said I wanted something light and colorful and playful and that kind of stuff given the theme.
I generated an image of that UI,
and then I told Codex to build that.
And once it did that with the camera roll
view that you're looking at right now,
I like that style.
And I told it “Go redesign
the settings page based on the same style.”
And it generated another image
and then implemented it.
Then it did
the same for the home screen.
So it's a pretty different
and new way to go about building UI.
So that's your eval, every time there's a new model
you're just rebuilding SnapCat?
I basically just look at how easy
it is for cats to take selfies.
Is it the best you've seen so far?
It's the best by far.
It is, it’s a lot better than the last time
I tried this a few months ago.
It is infinitely better than what
we managed to build in a full 24 hours.
Wow.
And I basically made this in one shot
last night in preparation for today.
Incredible, I love this.
Well, I guess now you have selfies of me
among your cats.
I'll text you one of them.
That's so cool.
Thanks so much for showing me your setup.
I love watching users
building with the Codex app.
Maybe to to close out,
what would be your advice for other founders or builders, who would like to master the codex the way you do?
You know,
I think it boils down to a few assumptions
that I've made early on that I think
have been really, really helpful for me.
The first one is assume it's possible.
Like if you have an idea, more often than not, it can probably be done.
The second one is assume you can do it.
That one's a bit more personal
but a lot of people
could be building these things.
And I think the blockers
that they think they can't.
I think assume you can.
In this case, maybe be in denial even that you can't do it.
It's usually true.
And the third one is when you try to get
something out of an LLM and it doesn't work,
this one's a bit difficult,
you have to put your ego aside,
assume it's your fault.
Don't assume that the tool isn't capable.
Assume you haven't found a way to communicate it or convey what you want just yet.
And I guess try again.
Like I've done a lot of trying again.
And I think that's what's gotten me
quite a long way into building things.
So that's probably the advice
I give to people.
I love that and it feels like the perfect note to end.
Anyone can just build anything.
It's true.
It sounds cheesy but it's true.
Thank you so much Matias. This was a great conversation.
Merci.
Thank you.
(speaking french)